i'm also
interested to play
other other games like
just 960 or fisher random as they call
it like that you have 960 maps instead
of one
yeah so for people who don't know a
fisher random chest chest 960s yeah that
basically just means that the pawns are
in the same way and
the major pieces are
distributed randomly on the on the last
rank only that there have to be
obviously bishops of opposite color and
the king has to be in between the rooks
so that you can castle both ways
oh you can still castle and you can
still castle but it makes it interesting
so
you still have
it still castles in the same way so
let's say the king is like
yeah what happens in that case yeah
let's say the king is in the corner
um
so to to castle this side you have you
have to clear a whole lot of pieces
well what would that thing look like
though no the king would go here and the
rook would go there oh okay um and
that's happened in my games as well like
i forgot about castling
uh and i've been like attacking a king
over here and then all of a sudden it
escapes to the other side i think um
i think fisher chest is
is good that it it's
the maps will
generally
be worse
than regular chest like i think the
starting position is
as close to
ideal for creating a competitive game
as possible but they will still be like
interesting and diverse enough that you
can play very um
very interesting games so when you say
maps there's 960 different options and
like what fraction of that creates
interesting games at the highest level
and this is something that a lot of
people are curious about because uh when
you challenge
a great chess player like yourself to uh
to look at a random starting position
that feels like it pushes you to play
pure chess versus memorizing live yeah
for sure for sure but that's that's the
whole idea yeah that's what you want and
uh how hard is it to play can you talk
about what what it feels like to you to
play with a random starting position is
there some intuition you've been
building up it's very very different
and
i mean
understandably engines have
an even greater advantage in 960 than
they have in
in classical chess
no it's it's super interesting and
that's why i also
i really wish that
we
played more classical chess like long
games
four to seven hours and
in
fish random chests just 960 because then
you really need
you really need that time even on the
first moves
what what usually happens is that you
get 15 minutes before the game you
you're getting told the position 15
minutes before the game and then you you
can think about it a little bit even you
know check the computer but that's all
the time you have but then you really
need to figure it out then
like
some of the positions obviously are a
lot more interesting in than the others
in some of them it appears that like if
you don't play symmetrically
at
the start
then
you're probably going to be in a pretty
bad bad position what do you mean with
the pawns with the pawns yeah
so that's the thing about that's the
thing about chess though so let's say
white opens with e4 which is which has
always been the most played move
there are many ways to meet that but the
most solid ways of playing has always
been the symmetrical response yeah uh
with the e5 and then there's the
the relopus there's the there's the
petrov opening and and so on and
if you just ban symmetry on the first
move in chess
you would get more interesting games oh
interesting uh or you you get more
decisive um
decisive games so that's the good thing
about chess is that we've played it so
long that we've actually devised
non-symmetrical openings that are also
fairly equal
and
symmetry is a good default but yeah
symmetry is a good default and it's a
problem that
by playing symmetrical armed with good
preparation in in regular chests it's
just a little bit
too easy to uh it's a little bit too too
dryish and
um i guess if you analyzed
if you analyzed a lot in in just 960
then
um the um
a lot of the position would end up be
being um
pretty drawish as well um but
because the random starting point is so
shitty you're forced to you're actually
forced to play symmetrically like you
cannot actually try and play in a more
sort of interesting
interesting manner
is there any other kind of variations
that are interesting to you
oh yeah there are there are several
so no castling chess has been
uh
has been promoted by former world
champion vladimir kramnik
there have been a few tournaments
with that not
any that i've participated in though um
i kind of like it also my coach uses
like non-castling
engines quite a bit to analyze
regular positions to just to get a
different
different perspective um so castling is
like a defensive thing so if you remove
castling it forces you to be more
offensive is that why
yeah it just yeah for for sure um it
seems like a i think it will be
different um
castling probably forces you to be a
little bit more
defensive at the start or i would guess
so
because you cannot suddenly escape with
the
with with the kings it's going to make
the game a bit slower at the start but i
feel like
eventually it's gonna um
uh it's gonna make the more games more
um
uh well less storage for for sure uh
then you have some weirder variants like
where the pawns can move both
[Music]
diagonally and um
and forward
and also you have self-captured chests
which is quite interesting so that pawns
can
or um
commit suicide yeah people can why would
that be i use a good move no sometimes
one of your pieces occupy a square i
mean
uh let me just set up a position let's
put it like
put it like this
for instance like here i mean there are
a lot of ways to checkmate for white
like this for instance or there are
several ways um but like this would be
uh
would be
uh oh cool
for people who are just listening yeah
basically you're bringing in a knight
close to the the whole the the king the
queen and so on yeah and you'll replace
the knight with a queen yeah that's
interesting so you have like a a front
of of uh pieces and then you just
replace them with the with the second
yeah uh that's cool i mean that could be
interesting i think also maybe sometimes
in
it's just clearance basically it adds an
extra element of
of of clearance so
i think there there are many um
many uh different variants i don't think
any of them are
better than
the one that has been played for uh at
least a thousand years but um
it's certainly interesting to
see
you